[Musique]
il y aura toute l'équipe avec moi ils
sont derrière et bien sûr mayer connu
voilà lucky luke
voilà la tristesse du gars quand même
c'est rien parce qu'on reçoit franck
dubosc pour boule et bill
et il y aura plein de jeu ce soir plein
d'infos il ya la rumeur du jour il ya le
scoop du jour et il ya bien sûr toute
l'équipe avec moi ce soir je vous
demande d'applaudir celui énorme et
c'est celle d'ailleurs celle qui va vous
allez voir son déguisement valérie
bénaïm applaudissements progrès
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce que j'avais dit cité par toutatis
fait une petite imitation d'astérix bien
sûr la potion magique par toutatis dit
des roma sur la très belle mère
venez avec moi quand elle valait le fer
d'or venez avec moi en mer allait le
faire deux ordres et le fer d'or dans la
rue dans la rue et on va demander aux
gens ce qu'ils en pensent non mais
attendez vous
il fait pas comme ça ici merci merci
beaucoup avec moi et vous êtes en
dosettes en liquide sur lui qui lui a
très bien être l'homme qui tire plus
vite que son ombre
oui merci venez un bonsoir bonsoir
souple soit vous arrêtez belime mais là
il vous arrêtez voiture est volée de par
toutatis ya c est ce que je peux monter
dans votre voiture
allez-y par toutatis
est-ce que je peux maintenant votre
voiture la compagnie à rome devant des
romains merci
allez on commence à voir là dedans ça va
allez vous mais c'est vrai on se connaît
mais c'est énorme et c'est vrai qu'on
ressent la chine y aller on a perdu mais
naïve c'est bon c'est réglé merci vous
allez au qu'on vous allez où les housses
et qui vous allez ou à la piscine où ça
très bien merci
allez allez allez on va aller on va
aller voir les autres c'est bon on s'est
débarrassé de ben haim c'est très bien
et bénigne c'est la tristesse absolue
on a avec nous benjamin castaldi
[Musique]
cette unification jour où sont mes
sangliers quoi où sont les sangliers
j'ai faim de tristesse tout on à enora
malagré en salle bals à fives et et où
la mer si on a on accueillir paix
derrière budaj pas isabelle morini bosc
[Applaudissements]
mettez-vous la météo mais cela est qu'il
faut tous mettez-vous l'aller attention
on a avec nous ce soir je vais regarder
je crois que da oui c'est bien mais on a
maxime galy regarder vaccine béni boule
qui roule n'amasse pas mousse et ça vous
plaît pas je me fait beaucoup de peine à
la personne depuis merci on a avec nous
mais attendez je vais regarder
ah oui comme matthieu delormeau regarder
le devait être un des mutations ne parle
pas des pulsions déconner on dirait
qu'ils pdg de renault jean luc lemoine
oublier certainement l'un est pas mal
merci merci merci merci à toi soya qui
la merci à huy à gâteau proust on fait
[Applaudissements]
elle est pas mal
bon délire enfin ça lâche qu'on a fait
ce soir
[Musique]
mais la tristesse va regarder je suis
allé dire un truc super intelligent m'a
fait ça va schtroumpfer ce soir allez
bon jean luc lemoine et là que j'aime
exo lui qu il est toujours au miracle on
va se répéter cette année
ah oui ah oui ah oui bah oui oui
malheureusement ya gilles verdez en dora
l'exploratrice applaudissements pour lui
[Applaudissements]
était mon père et enfin il y à la star
du jour ça fait une semaine qu'il n'est
pas là et oui et pour l'instant il ne va
pas dévoiler son visage il est impliqué
mais il a pour l'instant un masque de
l'ancien jean michel mr oui et ensuite
dans quelques instants vous découvrirez
le nouveau jean michel maire qui a fait
de la chirurgie esthétique
vous allez voir le salaire ici personne
ne l'a vue parce qu'il a gardé le match
on l'a pas vu je le découvre là parce
que je n'ai pas vu n'était pas au brief
tout ça jean michel lemaire est avec nos
amis qui apparemment est toujours aussi
lourd merci alors on a hâte de voir
oui merci on a hâte de voir qu'est-ce
qu'on verrait le vrai visage de jean
michel maire tout à l'heure il a fait de
chirurgie esthétique c'est vrai dur mais
on va pas dire une des faits et vous
allez voir il paraît que c'est frappant
c'est incroyable vous allez voir ça tout
à l'heure il se sent fraigne de ses
frais